welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Rakesh Mohan a professor in the
practice of international economics and
finance at Yale School of Management and
a senior fellow at the Jackson Institute
of global affairs at Yale prior to this
professor Mohan was deputy governor of
the reserve bank of india and Secretary
of the Department of Economic Affairs in
the ministry of finance today we talk
with him about his book growth with
financial stability central banking in
an emerging market which provides a rare
insider view into the development and
workings of central banking and the
financial sector in India welcome
professor Mohan thank you very much for
inviting me it's a real pleasure to be
here good get for the clean report
excellent let's begin with your book
give us an overview of it well as a
title says its growth with financial
stability as it turns out the whole
world is currently beset with financial
instability and therefore in that sense
i think that the book has come out at
about the right time one of the defining
characteristics of Indian economic
policy an atomic performance since our
independence in 1947 has been a
relatively consistent growth first
somewhat slow for 30 years and then much
faster the last 30 years but we've
always had financial stability so we
have not really had any banking crisis
in our more than 60 years of development
since independence so what the book
tries to do is to chronicle India's
development path over the whole period
but focusing particularly on fiscal and
monetary policies along with financial
sector policies and the role of course
of the settle bank that is Reserve Bank
of India in that the first part of the
book focuses on the coordination of
fiscal and monetary policies along with
sector policies essentially making the
point that it's extremely important to
coordinate each of these macro policies
as fiscal monetary and financial sector
policies and some extent in a way the
problems that Europe is facing right now
because of the crisis that they have a
real issue to the coordination of
monetary policy and fiscal policy is
because they have unified currency
universe monetary policy whereas
different fiscal policies so that is
illustrating in fact the problems that
arise me when you don't coordinate both
right so the first part of the book
essentially talks about how we have done
that over the years both during the
highly controlled period and then twas a
more open economy period and it makes
the point that as you move as in our
case we have in the last twenty years
from being a relatively closed economy
to an open economy that you have to do
this in a very gradual fashion so that
each sector then responds appropriately
of course in real time you never know
what is a correct pace of liberalisation
correct pace of economic reform but
somehow I think that we have managed
that relatively well the second part of
the book focuses specifically on the
financial sector and once again how we
have opened up the banking sector from
again until nineteen ninety between 1960
between 1970 98 98 become almost wholly
government-owned and slowly we have
introduced private sector banks and also
made the government owned banks much
more open and also developed financial
markets at the same time so against a
sort of a similar story of gradual
reform on a consistent basis so that
each institution responds appropriately
to the changes that are being made while
we also been developing the financial
markets that the equity market other
capital markets the debt market so that
the system becomes much more
market-oriented and is much more open to
the rest of the world I had an earlier
book which has published a couple of
years back it was called monetary policy
and I mobilized
me a practitioners view so that is
concentrated fully on monetary policy so
in this book the only aspect of monetary
policy are you deal with is the how
Indian monetary policy coped with
volatile capital flows and once again
this is topical because well the most
interesting is in the current crisis in
the West is that there were huge capital
flows between europe and the u.s. in
particular in both directions and how
they also had a role in causing sort of
problems that exist in our case in the
case of emerging markets it's not just
india but other emerging markets in asia
and latin america a coupe with large
volatile volatility and capital flows
and we had to then adapt our fiscal and
monetary policies and using a host of
different instruments including capital
account management techniques to be able
to have an independent monetary policy
while having some capricorn management
some capital controls and along with
along with development of financial
markets and the flexible exchange rate
and we are not that different in a way
from the other emerging markets and one
of the interesting things about the
current crisis really is that europe in
the u.s. in great difficulty while
emerging market countries in asia and
latin america have not had financial
sector problems as a consequence of this
of this crisis and india's among those
countries and so the third part of the
book basically deals with that and
finally there is a whole section of the
book on the global financial crisis and
the trying to document how it was
somewhat loose or accommodative monetary
policy in the early 2000s after the.com
crash combined with very light or light
touch regulation which basically took
the regulator's eyes off what is really
happening in the economy and then we had
all the problems of subprime and then of
course everything else that happened
including a huge explosion of financial
innovations and derivative
that contributed to the crisis okay so
we'll actually talk about each of those
pieces what I'm wondering is how how
your perspective differs on India's
economic growth in comparison to what is
widely believed about its economy well
i'm not sure if it does differ but
nonetheless i suppose that one thing
that I would say is that there is a
perception that we we are very poor
economic performance in the first 30
years he is 1950 1980 and then much
better one now that is really true in
terms of growth rates that the first 30
years we are but three three and a half
percent growth in gdp for over 30 a
period and then average of what six six
and a half percent last 30 years and of
course something like eight percent the
last seventy eight percent last ten
years so it's been going continuously so
one of the points that I do make is that
this has been a consistent story and
essentially going from low savings and
investment rates to higher savings
investment rate so it's been a
consistent growth over the decades in
domestic savings and investment while of
course in the earlier period the corner
is much more closed and the letter P
requires much more open but a consistent
story between different policy regimes
has been this this growth in savings and
investment and that is of course what is
necessary to achieve economic growth and
the other point is that even the first
30 years was a big departure or the
previous fifty to a hundred years where
we had zero growth so that three three
and a half percent was very low by a
current standard but nonetheless it was
a big departure from the previous 50
years okay what are some of the current
challenges India faces well the
immediate challenge of course just now
emerged really in since last six months
to one year that first after the 2008-9
crisis in the
world we were able to cope with that
quite well so that we also did a fiscal
stimulus like many countries did we did
the monetary stimulus as well and that's
how you coped with it that's what I hope
with it primarily and we were able to do
to restrict the impact on growth so that
in the first year that is 2008-9 it
growth just went down to what six point
eight percent and then came back up to
over eight percent in 2009-10 and 10 11
it's now that I think I think most
observers are expected that the world
would be coming out of the crisis in
2011-2012 but because of the eurozone
crisis now and also some of the problems
right it states to do with the fiscal
situation and some breakdown in Congress
in terms of the agreement and what to do
that we are now on the brink of another
recession in the developed economies so
as a consequence of that the immediate
challenge of course is to cope with what
may happen given the uncertainty in the
rest of the world okay and less
immediate challenge okay and how do you
work to sustain long-term growth what
are some of the strategies you think
would work well the some of the issues
that are emerging in India are much more
to do with human resource development
one big opportunity we have is that our
demographic situation is different from
other countries in the sense that over
the next 20 to 30 years the proportion
of people in the working age group say
between 20 and 50 would be much higher
than the other groups that is children
and old people so this is what people
characterize a demographic dividend that
will have that many more people working
so it's a greater opportunity to have
much higher growth also with more people
working with lower with fewer dependence
that you can have higher savings and
there
and consumption and and higher
investment so this is really should be
here at a very high growth however a
problem really is that we the stock of
education the stock of skills is low
even relative to some of our peers okay
and so a major challenge is to one make
sure that that the children now get good
health good nutrition and good education
for the future but also that people who
are already in the labor force
particularly say in the age of fifteen
to thirty who would therefore be there
in the next 20 years they're already in
the labor force that they need a lot of
training retraining and perhaps adult
education as you are saying that's a
major issue and along with that of
course much better health services than
we currently have is India also foking
focusing on technology yes we have we
were trying to bring in new policies in
higher education in trying to open up
that system as well because in the last
40 years or so we've basically had stage
controlled higher education now the many
more initiatives taking place because
once again what we're finding is that
there's a huge huge increase in the
number of people wanting to go to
college and and getting higher
qualifications and of course the economy
needs them to be able to invest in
higher technology so for example I'm not
currently working on long-term transport
policy for the country and one thing
that we find is that we do not have
enough expertise in any of the transport
sectors to be able to go in sometimes to
the next level what are the transport
sectors all of them railways roads civil
aviation urban transport ports and
shipping and the what has happened in a
lot and in the rest of the world
in developed countries in particular of
course it is not much greater
coordination between the different modes
so you have all kinds of logistics
companies which transport Freight over
different modes in a very efficient
fashion and that you therefore need a
lot of standardization on how you
transport these things for example a
container can happily go from say a
house or a factory to a truck to a train
to a plane or to a ship very easily but
many things have to be organized to do
that second with GPS technology being
available it's also much easier to track
everything and can also use that for
automatic tolling and things of that
kind third with the expectation of much
higher energy prices over the next 20 to
30 years we probably need to invest much
more in the railways and take both goods
and passengers off the roads because
they obviously partial an efficient
particularly in terms of energy use and
also possible climate change issues
coming up so we really do need to invest
a lot in energy efficiency in transport
because as we grow at something like
seven to nine percent over the next 20
years it will it will mean for example
that if we do grow at that rate well and
that's nine to twenty percent is here
yes so if you do good not nine twenty
ten percent a we never do twenty percent
see if you do if you do succeed in
growing the grid after hopefully the
world crisis gets over to give one
example of the challenges ahead that
energy usage would go by a factor of
four from where it is today to say 20
years from now which means that the
usage of fuels coal petroleum all this
will go a factor of four which means
that you have to transport four times
cool then you're
transporting today which means that you
have to lay down a lot of railway lines
much more roads and so on so everything
has an implication for everything else
and of course along with that that all
of this has to be done the financial
sector will have to be also expanding at
a similar rate to be able to finance all
these activities one thing I've
mentioned which I should have much
earlier is agriculture because still
more than fifty percent of the people
are engaged in agriculture and if we
ought to grow at these rates will have
much greater urbanization and also will
need much more technology change in
agriculture much greater productivity in
agriculture and that is much more
difficult to do because it's because
people are spread all over the country
low education levels low skill levels
and so once again we have to be
investing a great deal in bringing new
technology for different crops different
products fruits vegetables poultry meat
milk everything and also the
transportation also transition to trauma
and then transporting the stuff from the
farm to the market and all the things
that need to be done in between in terms
of building a cold chain so that that
that products from a from a farm can be
preserved in cold storage can go and
refrigerated trucks so there's a huge
amount of work with on the supply chain
and each of these means both investment
in money that is a tree infrastructure
also hopefully getting the best use of
new technology available in the world ok
you touched upon the global economic
crisis when we began how do you what
role do you think india has to play in
that i think unfortunately not much
really except making sure they don't
that we don't contribute to it but so
far we haven't the i guess the only
other role that we could play hopefully
is that one one thing that strikes me
for example is that just like United
States peer a federal system and so
there is structure of fiscal federalism
in terms of what the different Indian
states can do
in terms of borrowing and in terms of
the kind of intended nests that they can
get into there's certain disciplines to
do with that and so one of the issues
that is arising in Europe is and they're
having meeting today the the summit
between the Prime Minister's the leaders
of the European countries today and talk
about a fiscal Union and then obviously
what what they want is some kind of
discipline that some central authority
like the European Commission the
European Union will then have over the
different european countries now we have
that in the sense that we are of course
an integrated country and not different
countries but we have a large number of
states like the u.s. does and they all
borrow in the market but we do have
certain rules under which they operate
so that they don't get excessively
indebted I think that maybe as the
European fiscal Union does start
operating if they succeed this evening
and they're probably discussing this as
we talk here right now in Europe that as
they succeed and you have more of a
fiscal Union perhaps I think different
federal countries like the United States
India and others can then contribute and
finding ways and means for Europe
resolve their problems okay final
question what are some of the
conclusions you reach in your book
basically that very traditional
conclusions in a sense that in order to
grow on a consistent and financially
stable basis one you must have
responsible and prudent fiscal policy
that you do not get excessively indebted
and that you do contain populist
pressures for fiscal expenditures to
that monetary policy should be flexible
and not bound by a one particular rule
and that you do need to make sure that
you keep prices low inflation slowed
along with maintaining financial
stability and of course in the case of
an emerging market like ours you
really have to have an eye on on
inducing the financial sector to
contribute to growth third that whereas
financial openness and economic openness
is absolutely essential in the
globalized economy that you do need to
make sure that things that are not under
your control like for example currently
there's a crisis in Europe in the u.s.
we need to make sure that we have
appropriate capital account management
techniques including capital controls to
insulate ourselves from the ills of what
happened rest of the world but be open
enough in terms of flexible exchange
rates and open trade to get the benefits
of globalization and protect ourselves
from the ills of it very good thank you
so much for being here today and sharing
some of your work thank you very much
for this opportunity for more
information about professor mohan and
his work please visit our website at
yale edu backslash macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you